Are they set up
to be shame?
I'm going to see you
when I am.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
[Silence]
this is of course the book of
fasting. We are continuing in the
chapter regarding the days throughout
the year in which the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam generally or
specifically
encouraged that we fast as an
addition to our obligatory fast.
Yesterday morning we discussed the day
of
for a person who is not in Hajj and the
day of
and then the author adds.
So we discussed the day of we discussed
the narration of of
and how the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam in one narration encouraged
the fasting of the day of in another
that he himself did not fast the day of
when he was in Hajj. And so the fah have
summised from this that if a person is
in Hajj the sunnah for him is not to
fast the day of if a person is not in
Hajj the sunnah for him is to fast the
day of this is what's encouraged now
moving on to to the day of
Bestam.
[Silence]
Oh,
Muslim. him.
So,
one of the he narrates that he heard
Abdullahb say
that the messenger of Allah
fasted the day of and he commanded
the everyone else to fast it. Commanded
Does this mean that fasting the day of
is obligatory? No. What this means is
that he highly encouraged it because
is a command.
Right? When the ruling of something is
that it is mustab, it's a command. It's
just not binding. But it is a command.
Allah commanded that it he commanded it
of his of his slaves but it is not
binding
is a command and is a command. The only
difference is that obligatory or not
obligatory.
[Silence]
just like
is a prohibition but it's a prohibition
that is not binding. That's the
difference.
So he he he fasted the day of Ashur and
he encouraged that people fasted.
They said, "Oh messenger of Allah, they
meaning and the companions, some of the
companions, it is a day that the Jews
and Christians both exalt
meaning and some of them fast. The Jews
of Medina, they fasted the day of Ash.
So the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
wasallam said if the ne if next year
inshallah
when when next year comes around
we will fast the ninth day meaning along
with it. So we'll fast the ninth day
along with it. Ib Abbas tells us that by
next year the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam had passed away
is named
and it is the 10th day of Muaram the
10th day of the first month. Now
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
with respect to shared
shared acts of warship
between the Muslim and the Jews and the
Christians. The
there were a couple of stages that
went through but
namely he was to he sallall.aii wasallam
always encouraged
differentiating the that the Muslims
differentiate themselves in the way that
they worship from the other people of
the book. And this differentiating would
happen one of two ways. Either
it would be something that he would
discourage be done do the opposite
or
it would be done but done with a
modification to it that makes it
proprietary makes it particular to the
Muslim.
So for instance that we do the opposite.
For instance he says
he said pray in your shoes. Pray with
your shoes on. Why? Because the Jews do
not pray with their shoes on. Methan. So
here he commanded the opposite. The
opposite, right?
He said,
, set yourselves aside, differentiate
yourselves from the Jews. they
differentiate yourselves from the
Jews by growing the beards and trimming
the mustache.
So here he's commanding that the
opposite be done. But sometimes it's
something good that
should be done fasting the day
of. So how then do the Muslim
differentiate themselves from the people
of the of the book? A modification is
made to the act of worship fasting
in general. The Jews when they fast
especially in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam they would
fast until
the stars would be out and plentiful in
the sky that they would break their fast
only then not when the sun set. Fasting
is good. It's one of the five pillars of
Islam. So the Muslim fast, however, we
differentiate ourselves. How we fast as
soon as the sun sets, before the stars
even come out, right? And
is a good example of that. Fasting the
day of it's a good time. It's a time,
it's the day when Allah chose to deliver
and from the clutches of Pharaoh. And
it's a day in which Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
chose to
destroy Pharaoh and put an end to his
tyranny.
And so it's a day that we fast. However,
it's modified and that is that we fast a
day before the ninth day.
Some of the companions
understood from this that a person could
fast
the 11th day along with it and that
would serve the same purpose would it
not would serve the same purpose.
Why is this so important? Who are we
differentiating ourselves from the Jews
to?
Well, that's an important question. But
as hundreds of years and generations and
generations go by
and the Muslim spread throughout the
entirety of the earth and they live
wherever the Jews and Christians live
over time if we all celebrate exactly
the same day in exactly the same way
with the exactly the same act of
worship. What will eventually happen?
They may merge in that even if only in
that
and that is a mafida. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam made sure
that anything that is that is common to
the Muslim and other than the Muslim of
religious rights that it be modified
enough to where it is almost
unrecognizable
from the way that it is practiced with
the people of the book.
Subhan Allah.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam had the intention of fasting
the ninth day of Ash along with the
10th. The question is if a person were
to fast ash alone
would it count? Yes, it would count
because the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam fasted it alone. However, what
is the best way to fasted? By fasting
the ninth day along with the 10th or by
fasting the 11th along with the 10th.
Some scholars advised fasting the 9th,
10th and 11th. Why? just in case the
just in case the month is off in
calculation.
But this is a weak opinion. This is a
weak opinion because as we mentioned
before,
right? Fasting is when you all fast and
breaking your fast is when you all break
your fast. The crescent itself is not
the month. That is an indicator of the
month. So if for some reason the
calculation of the month of Muharam
happened to be slightly off that is the
day when it is recognized as ash and
therefore it is valid. So it is not
necessary to fast three days. The sunnah
and the extent of the prophet's sunnah
is the ninth and tth or the 10th and
11th.